moment of truth drop the ice cream
bergio
oh he's looking he's like
the guy saw him drop it
here you go sir
you lick that cone to win
sal volcano is one of the stars of
impractical jokers and he's bringing his
stand up to the virgin hotel tonight and
he joins us now hey sal how's it going
buddy how are you how's everything going
dude it is so great to see you man over
200 episodes on the show what is the
craziest response you have ever received
the craziest response uh
i and about a 90 year old woman proposed
to me at a show once so you never know
what's going to happen
and yeah are you are you married man are
you married
no sir but i did not but i did not
accept okay
okay what are your shows like what are
your stand-up shows like
they're really really funny i think
that's that's all you can ask me right
now
kelly and you have journey but i got to
tell you
for all them
i'll come to you tonight
comes to you tonight when it comes to
the show have you guys done your jokes
here because you don't like calling them
pranks do you we prefer to call them
jokes have you done the show here in las
vegas
we actually have we we've toured through
here on tour on stage but we filmed an
episode here in vegas as well
and uh yeah it was it was out of control
it was it was this is a crazy town man
this is it never ever disappointed yeah
that's las vegas for you do you uh did
you get a tattoo on one of the episodes
i did i got um i have a very
photorealistic tattoo of jaden smith on
both of my thighs
[Laughter]
yeah i swear one is with his black and
white and he's 15 and then i met him six
years later and he said that's outdated
and he came and posed for a new one on
my other thigh when he was 21. so not
many people have that and i and i and if
people come out tonight i will expose
them both you show them both and that's
because that was part of when the
episodes right that's why i had to get
that done
absolutely i was forced to do that i did
not choose to do that on my own you were
all right about it
hey are you a vegetarian now did i read
that
i was wow you're good i was a vegetarian
from age 15 to 22. but that was about 10
decades ago
you just didn't like the lifestyle or
just this meat had its way with you i
was like you know i was in college at
the time and i did that whole like this
is not right for the animals thing but
now it's funny i just thought of room
service i got a steak coming up right
now
so what are you doing you got the show
tonight what are you gonna do in town
you hang out in las vegas this weekend
you go out go to the clubs well i'm on
tour so i'm off by tomorrow but tonight
after i'll be hanging out at the hotel
uh going to get some dinner and i might
go catch another show or two actually go
see machine gun kelly tonight man i
might go see it i might i might pop by i
love it sal thank you so much man it's
great to have you on the show and have
fun tonight buddy
i appreciate you guys thank you so much